Justin Bieber has appeared on The Late
Late Show all week and last night was
his turn to take part in the game called
spill your guts or fill your guns yeah
so Justin had to choose between
answering really hard questions are
eating really gross food like bird
saliva and cod sperm so when it came
down to choosing between shaving off his
mustache you're eating ant yogurt with a
side of scorpion watch what he does and
eats what is in front of you mm-hmm oh
let me shave your mustache
[Applause]
hang on wait this is this is a serious
thing for Justin so and like while he
thinks about it Steve will you give us
some Betty's music while you take a
minute to think about that Steve no way
you're not going to do it you're not
going to do it a whole spoon and half
the Scorpion it'll grow back I can't
promise you I can't promise you that
this won't be harder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've got to swallow it buddy
[Applause]
I hadn't seen that before No so are you
okay do you need a second you're good I
feel like we should combine the hot side
of that and make one little special but
the worst idea ever okay i don't--hey
James Corden and I'll be the one who has
to eat the bad food okay now fans know
that justin has since shaved off his
mustache goodness after posting this pic
to Instagram that was like a big story
when he shaved that people really didn't
link it I didn't like it either that
make huge beeps fan baby so cute I know
maybe he's like his rebel phase you know
and now it's it's gone don't like
mustaches I yeah I like facial hair I
just don't know if I like like just the
stache
yeah like I like like a beard like I
like beards yeah yeah no I like five
o'clock shadow okay okay that means so
much about each other today okay so
another one of my favorite moments from
that segment was when Bieber was asked
to rank his wife Hailey's famous best
friends and he actually answers it
ranked these friends of hers from your
favorite to your least favorite Gigi
Gigi Hadid Kendall Jenner and Cara
Delevingne from your favorite to your
least favorite is no Kendall Gigi Cara
Delevingne I like that he's sort of
looked over at the audience because I
feel like Haley was in the audience and
he's like can I can I can I do this can
I answer this so Louis saying I'm loving
Justin this week he seems like such a
nice guy and I think misunderstood he
has a great sense of human you're just
saying to that workout video he did with
the toddler's yesterday it was amazing
it was so good I don't agree with that I
think he went through all of his stuff
unfortunately he had to go through it in
front of the camera yes yeah so I think
this is all great things that's
happening yeah and his past albums you
know he's talked to very openly about
breakup songs and then this new album is
is really heavily influenced by his new
wife and being husband and I think happy
and grad
did Christine is saying he's turned
himself around proud of him so yeah
there's just a lot of still comments
about not eating that bad food though
right Masaki is saying no no no nope
nope
Tia's saying all that hailey totally
called James and asked him to do this
that's true maybe she's the one who
suggested that game with her friends and
no I say yeah I think hailey has
something to do with this I love ya
these games are just really fun all
right so we're gonna do an et Canada
live game version and we're gonna play
that okay so yeah what's it card I said
hold on she responded card LV Jody's
taco oh he should have just eaten the
bowl of what scorpion the bull penis you
should have just eaten the bull penis
instead of answer that question that was
Cara Delevingne she responded to that
whole segment on social media and it
wasn't her angel speaking to her it was
actually Jody Davis who is also like an
angel yeah Jody was in my ear feeding me
the most beautiful cuz you felt like I
know I was like wait well is that